in 3 2 1 okay we're all gonna get our  guns out and we're gonna shoot not each  other with just the ground oh wait wait  wait  [Laughter]  three two one  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Laughter]  where are we supposed to go wait how's  your car still intact because it's a  good we're taking this car then wait  wait we can lose them in the subway the  subway where's that behind you sure  you're right maybe if you get underneath  it I can rip off of you okay yeah ramp  on my body yeah you guys go down into  the subway  that's what we've been saying we've been  doing all right that didn't work hang on  am I in the right place drive your car  here  Wow  [Applause]  [Laughter]  [Laughter]  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Laughter]  Oh God is a can I middle finger him I  can't turn all the way around  [Music]